hey everybody welcome in the studio wow  look at that microphone that is  something huh cpac is coming up there's  a ton of speakers i'll be covering it  the three most unhinged speakers are  going to be number one  candace owens candace owens has been so  weaponized in her rhetoric anti-vaxx  claiming maybe bob saget died from the  vaccine she's going to be completely off  the rails number two tulsi gabbard why  is she even speaking at cpac i thought  she was the last real liberal and blah  blah blah  no  so tulsi will be completely out of  control and then of course donald trump  donald trump will show up he'll lie  he'll fire people up he will maybe  allude to what he's planning for 2024  you could if if trump is speaking he's  always the most unhinged we'll be  covering it live let me know who you  think will be the wackiest at cpac this  year